It is time for
our "Get Up" makeover
six-month follow up.
I love this.
I know
how you do.
You might remember Amy.
Sure.
Whose co-workers thought
this overworked
people pleaser
needed a day of pampering
and a new look to snag
her a man.
Oh.
Wow, that is hideous.
Ohh...
Somebody's gonna
die alone.
So six months ago,
Lisa, our
makeover expert--
I love her.
I know.
She's the best in
the business.
She went to work
and she turned that
into this.
( applauding )
That's a beautiful
woman.
I know.
She looks terrific.
She looks great.
So Lisa is at her
house live--
Hmm?
And we're gonna
check in
and see how she's been
maintaining her new look.
Hi guys, I am so excited
to see Amy
and how
pretty she looks.
( screaming )
Oh!
( laughing )
I'm sorry,
I think I may
have the wrong house, I--
Amy?
Yeah, you
have the right house.
623 Supermodel Lane.
Get in here,
you lifesaver.
Oh.
Hi!
Oh, my God.
I knew that you
would think
I wouldn't be able
to keep this look going on,
but check it out!
I did it, girl!
We did it!
What happened to your--
your hair?
Well, you know what,
I knew if I shampooed it,
I would lose
this beachy-wave thing
that you guys created,
so I just been
skipping it.
I mean,
you were right.
I don't have to
blow-dry it.
I don't
have to wash it.
It's so easy.
No, I definitely
never said
you didn't
have to wash it.
I thought you
said that.
I never said that.
So...
Why is there an elliptical
in the bathtub?
Oh, you know what?
Oh, my God.
I never had space
for it before,
but I just
thought, you know,
now that the bathroom's kind
of like irrelevant,
just go for it,
you know?
I mean, why not have
a fierce booty
to match my
slamming new style?
Oh, my God.
You haven't been
showering, is that--
Uh, no, no.
But people have been
showering me...
with compliments.
Well, it looks like you
haven't even
washed your face.
Okay, okay,
yeah, you know what?
I loved that smokey-eye thing
that you guys did,
so I knew
I couldn't recreate it,
so I just let it
bake in.
Well, you didn't have
to recreate it.
It's just mascara,
just an extra layer.
It's easy.
Right, right, right,
but I'm like a total idiot.
So that's why it's important
that I'm hot.
Have you even changed
your clothes?
No, I didn't.
And now I can't.
( man )
Excuse me, ma'am...
is this your residence?
We've had some complaints
about a foul smell here.
Hi, I live here.
Uh, the neighbors are
worried that
someone may have died.
Oh, no,
nobody died,
but my body is sick.
Hi, I'm Amy.
Boyfriend alert.
Hi.
( giggling )
♪